oh my god yeah I mean
[Music]
nice Skip's Congrats you're in [ __ ]
debt I think you need to be more Better
Homes and garden and less QVC got it
you're welcome you're welcome to take
care of thank you thank you so much man
I appreciate that
how are you nice to meet you man I've
been following you for so long
thank you Mike 15 years us I appreciate
my pleasure 8 6 7-5 3 oh my hotel room
in 20 minutes
email Steph land and Tyler and push in
15 minutes we'll do it 1115 I hope you
guys uh personal got to go work out with
Jordan who's been building my muscles
I'm gonna show you behind the scenes
interactions on email texts DMS in daily
B's because I think it can show some
color I keep saying watch what I do not
what I say this is one of the ways that
I can extend the way that I hope you
watch me rock and I have is started
[Music]
great thank you
Boise Idaho speech just to decline calls
vaynermedia good just now that little
phone thing that was the best [ __ ]
[ __ ] you've ever got how many peeps this
is who I was looking for yeah touch
Chicago take it out
do not let me see okay show everyone the
age of space Wow
all the cars different by the waves so
the cameras either this will you
so carry your business guy up smart
hostile in paying attention to Marius
yes smart the smartest some I wish do me
a favor do not take your eyes off the
eight yes all right push in for push in
yeah do not check eyes over okay pay
attention I know you're all about
frankly I can't even like I start from
the corner I'm like how that happened
for you guys that really know how to do
it yeah it's some different [ __ ] bro
yeah I'm just just touch a card doesn't
yeah that one okay this doesn't actually
all see it okay one of those types of
tricks or I suggest a Jack of Clubs this
is what we're gonna do I want you to
hold your hands off me
alright this is what I wanna do I'm
gonna take the jack you guys see that
I'm gonna put the jack into your hand
like this I can't pick your hand on top
and this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
take the hit of seven of Hearts
alright squizzles to Jack what's the
seven you guys all see that I'm gonna
take the seven about this here we go I
think it's so [ __ ] hard my whole
[ __ ] life I'm holding with my whole
life oh that was crazy
my man to the YouTube hustlers that just
watch that when did you realize social
and content was really changing your
world what was like my university I'm
twenty three or twenty one that's what I
started making content I did it
relentlessly where I was in London no
I'm what platform first I started on
YouTube didn't find much success went to
Facebook and then Facebook I found pages
that could share my videos and you were
hitting them up message I helped on
I said I got one main page for him here
that shared me my page went from 100
likes to the 7,000 likes every night
notice that there's most important part
he was biz Devon and hitting up a
hundred people and saying look at what I
look at look what I'm doing
finally somebody said yes yeah and
that's it not serendipity you went out
and took it
yeah and that gave me the motivation
five Dante took on my first viral video
that took me from about ten thousand to
half a million likes overnight and then
you know all the way up now not just hit
12 million followers yesterday so
sometimes it's really amazing to the rat
yeah let's go
[Applause]
thank you dear Aki are you filming this
where do you live well first of all
listen listen listen listen that's gonna
happen now I think it's so crazy you see
you're funny you're smart you know me
you know that now I'm getting click now
I'm blacked out and want to destroy your
face I'm gonna do something for real
based on what you just said I want you
to come to vaynermedia for a day I'll
pay for your flight in the hotel and
Dorine during that day will play
bubble-hockey and we'll see what's up
all right do you rock let's interview
you know it's yeah it's I got to figure
it out take your bag off is how we're
doing it you told me to be more vlog II
here we go
it was really good today right yeah by
the way I'll only be interviewing d-roc
after I feel like it was good it was a
good one guys this might we might have
to put this whole keynote on on YouTube
which I'm not trying to do actually
these days Facebook is where I'm putting
mostly kina or are we doing the Gary Vee
Gary Vaynerchuk channel thing
okay so we'll be doing some stuff it's
coming soon all right guys I'm gonna
give my official prediction to Jay Kim's
each week on snapchat this the official
official like bet money on it
Raiders oh my god yeah I mean you've got
a that's got to be a core of this whole
episode there's nothing more ridiculous
than that literally like this wonderful
kind moment at the airport
[Music]
so that that is unbelievably awesome you
told me that you sort of do that at
games like you like attack the
individual you got to see and realize
yeah oh my God he's actually he doesn't
give a [ __ ] no no no no Josh Josh you're
confused my friend I'm a winner
you root for winners dick first let me
give you your power it's yours thank you
very much who are you I'm Gary
Elsa hello I said I'm deep with the
lyrics I'll shoot everything walking I'm
all precision back there should I put it
out there that high if the Jets lose
every game I'll shave my head belt
should I shave my head if the Jets lose
every game yeah
sitting down with Gary Vee put in the
[ __ ] aside he said you found your
lane so Brian is just a mattr job
don't ever sugar-coated a cuz that don't
help us train they want successor they
want sympathy
it's just how it sings I'd rather not
smile fake I'd rather keep it on Gary
I'll flick the switch and hit the lights
and see who shines when it's scary pull
the trigger